I found something you gotta check this
out you place for games anymore
yo what's this
[Applause]
Jumanji pick a character and you're that
person in the game Bethany you went it
all spend my life staring at a TV screen
it's my hair
where's rest of me
oh my God we're in different people's
body
bethenny don't look at it I'm an
overweight middle-aged man wait a second
where's my phone don't cry don't cry
don't cry
I think we've become the avatars we
challenge
welcome to Jumanji
this is a video game which means we each
have three lives let's go I'm Alex watch
you step in here so gnarly we can help
each other we all have special skills
weakness nothin I hate this game
everybody else got good stuff weakness
Hey
yes cake is my weakness good weapons
valet what is that I think it means you
carry my weapon - give them to me when I
tell you to don't let this new body get
your butt water we have to work together
I think it's a staring contest who's
good at staring and not blinking
handsome I'm amazing at it
[Music]
I like can't even with this place
we gotta go get on my back
oh no I'll carry you come on I would
rather die get on my gosh no I'm going
down
[Music]
biggest bone cake cake isn't that your
weakness something happening to me
you're mocking my shaking I'm just still
black yes okay fine everything is fine
it's all good
[Applause]
you